il y avait ce bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin au lundi 1 ce
samedi à près de 80 rassemblements sont
prévus à travers l'hexagone notamment à
paris xii allez-vous même défilé cet
après midi alors que nous d'abord je
souhaitais vous me promettez remercier
toute la famille gilet jaune à auquel
j'appartiens chèrement d'ailleurs et de
200 combats depuis c'est plus de plus de
deux heures déjà
et tous les manifestants qui descendent
dans les rues pour dire stop
justement à à ce projet
mc revenir parce que souvenez vous
emmanuel macron à avait dit lors de sa
campagne présidentielle que ceux signés
était notre projet mais en fait c'est ce
qui est bien l'heure c'est pas notre
projet du tout et pour répondre à votre
question oui je serai à la manifestation
aujourd'hui et j'espère que ça sera
bondé de monde pour envoyer un signal
fort cette loi est liberticide
alors depuis le mois de novembre à vous
êtes mobilisés pour dénoncer justement
ce texte que vous estimez controversé le
collectif contre la proposition de loi
exige d'être toujours d'être reçu par
emmanuel macron est ce que vous pensez
qu'un dialogue est possible
écoutez moi donc j'ai les jaunes je
prend pas trop au dialogue avec le
président emmanuel macron au souvenez
vous un gilet jaune ont essayé à
plusieurs reprises d'essayer d'avoir un
dialogue avec eux en vain et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en fin de discours avait
rendez vous avec eux alors là à la
proposition de loi on sait qu'elle a été
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale en
première lecture elle doit être examiné
au mois de mars par le sénat qu'est ce
que vous attendez vous attendu et une
modification de certains articles
les articles controversés 24 21 22
le retrait total de 7 soit un retrait
total vous savez quand quelque chose ne
fonctionne pas contient un loup ça sert
à rien de continuer en fait vous savez
cette cette loi strictement à rien
puisque vous savez bien maintenant que
les gilet jaune en été les précurseurs
sur l'utilisation de la vidéo en live
dans les manifestations et justement si
on a commencé à filmer le durant ces
manifestations c'est que c'est qu'on se
sentait déjà plus du tout en sécurité
face à des personnes qui étaient censés
assurer notre sécurité
donc aujourd'hui vous savez il ya un
arsenal juridique qui protège déjà les
personnes qui pourrait filmer ou prendre
des photos sur n'importe qui d'ailleurs
que ce soit des forces de l'ordre ou à
que ce soit des journalistes ou bien un
citoyen lambda qui qui voilà qui
appellerait au meurtre à la violence ou
des insultes
je ne comprends pas bien je comprends
pas bien le 7 7 7 laux voilà enfin si on
peut le comprendre parce que vous savez
quand on vous attend manifestations et
que vous voyez des propos qui ne
comptent pas leurs et rio
cela veut bien dire qu'il ya des offres
qui ont été données de par leur
hiérarchie et s'ils n'ont pas le r et o
c'est que il ya quand même comment
dirais-je une volonté de faire des
choses qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
corrects
je prends un exemple durant les
dernières manifestations les forces de
l'ordre maintenant n'attendent plus du
tout qui et les jets de pierres ou des
dg de quoi que ce soit envers eux à leur
encontre des insultes vous marcher
tranquillement et au bout de toutes les
10 minutes où tous les carrefours vous
avez les forces de l'ordre qui vous
rentre dedans qui tabasse tout le monde
tout le monde je dis bien tout le monde
sans raison ça c'est clair j'ai des
vidéos problème et vous voyez par
exemple cette fameuse manifestante gilet
jaune au moun ki qui se fait attraper
arbitrairement et qui maintenant est
devenu
le symbole savez en ouvrant le parapluie
on donne maintenant le signal aux blacks
blocs de tout passé voyez c'est une
façon pour eux de faire tout et
n'importe quoi sans être réprimandés
merci beaucoup en tout cas il y ades
d'avoir réagi avec nous ce matin sur
notre antenne avant cette manifestation
donc un prévue cet après midi je
rappelle que vous êtes gigean